hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on for honor again today I've
officially hit rep 5 with JJ so we're
gonna be hopping into some duels [ __ ]
like that I'm playing a lot of breech
beforehand so I've been grinding a lot
been playing with a couple of the
youtubers and stuff like that so
hopefully we can I've done I don't have
too much experience with JJ I did just
fly a rep 13 JJ by the name of Hulk he's
also the number one shoe go key on Xbox
so or maybe in the world as well but I
did have a bit of experience flooding in
the 1v1 side of things with him but
we'll see how I do with other people in
different matchups so let's get started
with today's video all right we have a
rough one Musha now I'm not used to her
traps I've said I've stated this many
times in this in streams that after
playing thousands of hours of this game
and you know playing that a way that you
should be blocking every mover somehow
carrying and now having to adapt to that
is very hard so it's gonna be a bit
difficult to I still am not used to her
traps as much but that'll be a quick be
a quick kill right there one thing
that's good about JJ though is that if I
try to go for like if I try to parry one
of her heavy attacks what I'm probably
most likely going to do is throw it
early and so - maybe bait her into
throwing the trap even if she wasn't
going to and then Sifu out of it so that
I can dodge it cuz I don't want to get
caught by it her lights are also crazy
fast as well but that's for a different
day got caught him a hyper armor she got
the block though but she got caught in
the hyper armor damn I can't believe I
missed that I backed up a bit that's why
that's gonna add her nice
that's quick yeah she's been really
aggressive as well especially during the
dodge attacks you really just want to
wait you don't want to be getting too
aggressive especially dodge attacks just
in case um personally I don't find it
worth it to even parry his dodge if it's
the heavy one because then there's the
option where it was the possibility
where you get too cocky and then you try
to parry it but it ends up not being
it's not the move because then he goes
for the soft pain to light it's just not
good so honestly I bought it I just
block it as much as I can as she got
that interesting faded good stuff that's
a quick three oh sweet
not bad I'm really getting used to the
seafood here as well it's a crazy good
move I'm honestly just been loving
dodging people's moves with seafood
basically since it's like in stance it's
a lot of fun alright next we have a rep
five anusha and very interesting kind of
just got off the other was I think rep
one Musha so this would be an
interesting fight probably very very uh
I would assume very more experienced
than the other new chef but so I'm
expecting to get lights pans this whole
time missed the guard break nice got
cocky
yeah you just want to make sure that
after he follows up with that little
follow up light if JJ even does that
follow up light that you don't get you
don't know you wait a little bit I would
assume because I would I would just
suggest cuz then he might just do
seafood again and that's not good
damn I fell into the trap oh I should
come into car break little quick swipe
nice house uh my heart was racing a
little bit when I when I whipped out the
unblockable
I didn't I don't whip out the
unlockables as much I usually try to not
let them rip just because they're really
easily parried and I'm surprised them
the forge wasn't actually incredibly
loud this time I was impressive
oh she's she's starting to know that
should've been a heavy [ __ ] I didn't
think that that was I thought that for
some odd reason that was they just the
regular move I didn't think that that
was a nice what I was trying to say is I
didn't think that that was a light
attack I thought that was a heavy for
some reason uh that's why didn't I just
went for the zone but it worked out you
know quick three Oh sweep against
musha's lotsa new shoes two new shoes so
far and hopefully we won't get a third
next game all right we have a rep 44 she
go key I don't have any I don't have too
many moves to get rid of his hyper
armour you know like a double hit kind
of like how warden and shinobi have but
I've been getting better at swinging at
likes so as I say that I got the [ __ ]
just destroyed there but I was I was
definitely doing better I would get hit
and light so hopefully I can prove that
I big trade friend
damn yeah I uh I thought for some reason
you have this hyper armor but that was
totally my mistake I was playing uh I
was playing a little bit aggressive but
I should have let him throw a couple
moves and stuff like that that's
definitely my fault I need to let you go
ki do his thing you know let ya throw a
light so I can parry it and then
hopefully not screw up the parry
punished like I've done multiple times
it's totally my fault let's see if we
can uh try to improvise with this damn
guard break
damn dude I should have been a Perry
I uh I definitely [ __ ] up the timing
there that's my bed yeah I [ __ ] up the
timing uh when he did the demons embrace
I dodged and I just froze up like I
press zone and it's just didn't register
so I think I kind of like froze up it
looked like yeah I think that might have
been an accidental miss click by him you
usually should go if he's just kind of
don't just demons and bristling Duccio
like that it's very awkward of them
that's gonna be a big trade for him yeah
it's an extra six damage it sucks damn
bro do it I cannot believe I'm missing
these lights I feel so stupid right now
got him a fiber armor that's a good play
I still can't believe I'm missing these
lights I feel really stupid
I was parrying these like nothing like
an hour ago and now I'm just not getting
them for some reason I don't know what's
wrong with me today
what's whatever I mean I'm up one so
it's not too bad
maybe he'll probably throw a light Dan
vez should've been buried as well big
salt right now I'll just get my stamina
back real quick what are you doing ah
[ __ ] I thought I fainted it oops
bad timings dude do come on man I'm so
annoyed I keep missing these
there we go all right so I said in the
beginning that I was really good at
parrying she go keys lights and I didn't
Perry a single light throughout that
entire flight that was definitely my
fault I feel like if I through a lot if
if I parried those lights this match
would have been over way quicker but
it's whatever though I still got the win
hey guys that's gonna be end of movie
today hope you guys did enjoy just a
couple bit of duels for ijj didn't rip
five I know a couple other youtubers
stuff like that are really high up you
know rep seven rep ten and stuff like
that but you boys a lot of
responsibility still I forgot school got
a lot of other things I have to do it so
I don't really have as much time as some
others do to grind this game let me know
what you guys if you guys are playing
the new marching fire heroes let me know
what your guys's rep is while we're on
the topic like I said I'm rep five with
the other characters I haven't really
played much of them I don't think I'm
even close to rep one or even halfway
there to those guys I've just been
playing exclusively JJ this big thick
boy right here hey guys hope you guys
did enjoy the video oh yeah like the V
if he did enjoy subscribe for new I
cover the informational side of
foreigner that being balanced changes
here all updates patch notes leaks and
all that type of stuff as well as some
JJ gameplay and some gladiator gameplay
as well so what that guys think guys for
watching the video like to illustrate
videos would be on screen if you guys do
want to check that out like I said
greatest err day make parts in the video
peace out guys take care
[Music]